on prime crime it might be somebody that
you want to have sex with or somebody
that you might want to kill
oh our continuing story of renowned
serial killer
samuel little when he put their hands
around our throat he wanted to swallow
so he could feel their adam's apple
strangle a woman i like that in me for
psychological i guess
what made him tick what's really
interesting here
is the type of victims that he selected
and his relationship with his mother
what it was like to speak with him
when you see his hands you'll see just
how monstrous they are
he may still murder this even though he
was
70 years of age and do we know about
all of his crimes tell me about mary
anne she's what you not basically call a
[Music]
transgender
hey there everybody i'm jesse weber and
welcome to prime crime
this is where we do a deeper dive into
the most high profile
and memorable true crime cases this is
part two of our analysis of samuel
little
the most prolific serial killer in
united states history
previously on prime crime i grabbed my
legs and pulled
to the water that's the only one that i
ever
killed by drumming we know of at least
93
women who were murdered he actually told
police that he found it
sexually satisfying to rape and kill
women
he was not going to stop it was
squeezing hard enough for
the breath we could be cut off because
he did this
same mo over and over again he got very
good at it
prosecutors and the police were able to
actually
pin a case on him until he left his dna
californian actually had a case where
they had run dna on a cold case
and they came back to a identical person
in sam little
for years sam little proclaimed his
innocence but after a jury convicted him
of murdering three women
he began to confess you're so valuable
to society at this point
this guy definitely was ready to talk as
soon as he knew
he wasn't going to be receiving the
death penalty he had
his black chick up in the car just got
through
coming off i absolutely believe
in his credibility of the stories that
he told and soon cold cases sometimes
decades old
started to be solved i don't go back to
the same city sometimes
fuck me another great
i mean y'all got only buying him for
sure
through little's interviews with
authorities in the media we've developed
a clear picture of his killings
how he was finally caught and why he
ultimately confessed
but let's take a step back how did sam
little
become sam little sometimes to get to
the end
you have to start at the beginning new
york times best-selling author jillian
lauren knows that well
as she spent hours interviewing and
studying little
i speak with his family they ask me all
the time how did this happen why
why why early childhood sexual abuse
physical abuse yeah you were born in
1940 right i was born in 1940 okay
he went to reform school for stealing a
bicycle it's called boys industrial
school
in ohio his family will also tell me he
was
he was nothing but trouble even before
he went there
then he just got abused
and abused and abused
he grew up in georgia his mother was 16
when she was pregnant and she was in the
sex worker industry
he talked about his mother his mother
had left him
on the street corner when he was
described as being so young he was
almost a toddler what's really
interesting here is the type of victims
that he selected
and his relationship with his mother the
victims that he chose were
very vulnerable they were sex workers
they were
some of them were addicted to drugs
these were low-income
minority neighborhoods she was an
alcoholic
and she couldn't catch a trick no more
she was she was in a position where
a whore that was couldn't do nothing
the women in little's life arguably
defined him and also
shaped his criminal career that includes
his longtime girlfriend
aurelia gene dorsey you were a traveling
man
all your life right how did you make
money to
find cars shoplifting me and my lady
jean was uh she was
70 something yeah she's about 30 years
older than me
and he met her in in jail in 1970
and that was who was shoplifting all the
goods
that allowed him to travel from state to
state to state city to city
killing these prostitutes so he was a
thief by day and a killer by night
she shoplifter and i was the driver
and we grow the country everywhere there
i stop in places
overnight in the motels she
she's an old lady you know man i'd go
out the street looking for a
girl that's how i got around so many
places
from 1971 until dorsey's death in 1988
little and dorsey made quite the team
whether she realized it
or not because of her you were able to
kind of go around
right because well she had that the
money coming in yeah she
knew you were going out with women yeah
as you know she didn't know that there
was like no
killing going on oh she
i kind of wonder if she was this
maternal
replacement figure and
so there was this respect and adoration
towards her
aside from the reported 47 disciplinary
infractions he received at reformatory
school
in his younger years little was
repeatedly arrested for burglaries
and even assault however it was in 1970
when things really change
the first victim i had was in uh
by january february of 1970
okay over in miami coconut grove miami
yeah first killing did you know that you
wanted to kill her
yeah yeah i had
desired strong desire to
kill her coming up inside the mind of a
serial killer
women so i had that enemy for the
gut it was psychological i guess
[Music]
pulled her body out and wrote it down
there and i heard a secondary road
of noise that meant she was still
rolling
convicted murderer samuel little spent
his youth in and out of trouble for
various offenses
but it's believed that on january 31st
1970
little killed his first victim mary
brazley
this was the start of a 35-year killing
spree
which little claims resulted in 93
murders
so why did he start well for one only
four years earlier
he had been arrested for assaulting a
different woman
i believe that was the impetus for him
to say
i will not leave a witness alive again
yet little's interviews with
investigators in the media
revealed another motivation for not only
how he ended up choosing his victims
but how he killed them one of the themes
that we believe in reference to sam
little was
the neck he he was excited by the
victim's neck
you pick the ones that you think you're
going to kill nurse no
if you want the benzo higher than that
got a smooth
neck and turned as a child i
i
so you pick them out by the way that
their neck looks because if the neck
looks good
then there might be somebody that you
want to have sex with or somebody that
you might want to kill
what what's what's the thought
when he put their hands around our
throat he warned him to swallow
so he could feel their adam's apple if
it was a pretty neck
you were probably going to be a victim
if you had an ugly neck maybe maybe not
so much
the other stuff is red wasn't don't be
important to me just
she could be skinny and narrow right she
could be ugly
she could be fat she couldn't be skinny
she ain't gonna be
fat cause the fat one's next right
right he actually felt that he could
have murdered before 1970.
he used to touch women's necks while he
would be engaged with sex
with them you had had that desire before
that
i had it but it wasn't uh but you never
did it at all
no just the choking but never all the
way to death
but it was a fantasy of his and when he
did it
it was easy and it was something then
that he didn't want to stop doing
he just went out of control i guess and
then after that
it was built up crescendo interestingly
sam little's last known murder occurred
in 2005
that was seven years before his eventual
capture
so why did he stop little got old and
that's why he stopped in 2005
at the age of 65. that's a career
he still had the same urges to kill
women
but physically he was failing
he knew that he might get caught if he
continued to try to physically kill a
woman
and then more importantly tried to get
rid of their body
sam little's criminal career of sexual
assault and murder can be characterized
in many ways
but how little himself views what he did
well that's something he was very
particular about
he's a man that did not want to admit
that he raped anyone in his own mind
he wanted to be known as a killer
rather than somebody that would
have to take by force sex from the woman
while we were dancing she says uh you
want you want to go riding
that's just you know the party's over so
she had
a arm at home walking to the car he's
very
invested in the idea that he does not
hate women he loves women
little rock tell me what that girl
looked like
oh man i loved it most people luckily
don't have to know about the mechanics
of strangulation but
it hurts and he did hate women
and then i would you know we went
further you know
i choked her there little was an erotic
aggression subtype of rapist
and these rapists choose
women who are vulnerable they like to
control them
they act out very aggressively and they
act on impulse
this subtype is the least common of all
subtypes with only about 10
of serial rapists having this erotic
aggression he was
so attached to this idea that he didn't
hurt them
and god made him the way he is god gave
me this twisted desire
where sex and death got all
twisted up inside of me like a pretzel
that was my weakness
i guess i never could get that out of my
mind mixed up with sex and he would say
well
killing somebody is no different than
stealing a cookie from a cookie jar
because every sin is the same and that's
jesus and that's the bible
and i said actually i think there's kind
of a hierarchy
what's the first commandment an answer
don't wave this book around as a
justification
for killing women if you never read it
he was killing women for sex
that was sex for him when we return
sitting across
from a murderer yeah he was scary to
bear
like psychologically he's frightening
why did you look down here i was trying
to find a place to put the body oh i see
beginning in 2018 and already serving
life sentences for multiple murders
serial killer samuel little decided to
confess to his killings in a series of
interviews
this helped investigators solve many
unanswered questions about
numerous cold cases what was truly
amazing though
was little's ability to recall details
of his crimes
from decades earlier las vegas described
the las vegas victim that was in 93.
she was gonna thin dark skinned
about 40 years old when she was out
there hustling
how tall was she she was about five five
five
three when we were speaking to him
he would go from talking to us in the
third person to all of a sudden
being there and he would have a far-off
look as if he's
right there doing it we over here behind
a furniture factory
parked
he was able to say specifically where he
dumped her body down a hole
chefs go down laid down to the basement
but he had a real
rail around it two where he couldn't
fall down there steps
you had to go around to the steps so i
threw the threw it
on the steps mr little had a very
keen memory it was almost photographic
he never took
trophies his trophy was up here in his
mind
he would relive in his jail cell and his
holding cell each of these
killings over and over again remember
some young lady you dumped
uh yeah tires
during his confessions he is smiling
he's reminiscing
it's nostalgic for him i think that
these were good times for him
little also shocked the world by
actually drawing sketches of his victims
which investigators have been using to
solve these cold case murders
he remembered some of the names of the
victims he remembered
wardrobe he remembered buttons on some
of their clothing and zippers
this went back all the way to the 1970s
it takes a special type of intelligence
to have that
ability i saw that he drew petechial
hemorrhaging
in their eyes which is what happens when
you strangle women
i was looking for evidence i was like
what's the detail
that he noticed about them that could
possibly
connect it to a confession connect it
eventually
hopefully you know to a cold case to a
jane doe
the people who interviewed sam little
found themselves in a unique position
they were there to find out more
information about these killings
yet in the process they became close to
a brutal murderer
we started writing letters he sent me a
christmas letter
and he talked about wanting to help me
solve any case that he thinks he did
if i would send him the information he
will do whatever he could
our conversations veered from uh
sports boxing my kids
my meat loaf he liked to hear what it
was like to
actually be a human being it made him
feel like one for a minute
and then he would talk about murdering
despite any pleasantries or bonding
don't for one second
think that interviewers ever forgot who
they were speaking to
i'll just say that when you see his
hands you'll see just how
monstrous they are i didn't feel in
danger myself because i knew
that he didn't mind men
if my daughter in that room alone if
anyone's daughter was in that room
he may still murder that person even
though he was
70 years of age he felt he could get
away with it
he would did you ever shoot any of these
girls
shoot yeah with a gun
it was really scary i was always sort of
calculating
how long it could take to really do
damage
and how long it would take for a guard
to get to me
like psychologically he's frightening up
next
do we know about all of little's
killings or are there more
stay with us i think all court shows are
the same
we're talking about your father guilty
or not guilty
guilty think again judge caprio rules
with common sense
i was having contractions i was rushing
to the hospital inspector quinn what
does justice demand
jail and compassion i'm going to take
the circumstances into consideration
the best court experience i've had
clearly judge he's been in a court
before
get caught in providence
hi i'm dan abrams in the exploding legal
and true crime genre
law and crime is the only network that
has it all good evening and welcome
this is a complicated case don't really
jump to conclusions
welcome to prime crime tonight another
day of drama between both sides
from multiple live trials daily to
original and compelling programming
the lawn crime network is everywhere and
we invite
you inside the jury box this
is law and crime
do you think her body might have been
hidden where you dumped her over that
fence
or do you think somebody would have
found it eventually yeah i think it's
very true i was
very rarely could have found her through
serial killer samuel little's
confessions
law enforcement and prosecutors from
different states were able to solve
dozens of cold case investigations and
little was finally convicted
and sentenced to multiple life terms of
imprisonment
for several murders at the time of this
taping
over half of his killings have been
confirmed he spoke about 93 different
cases so far
from my understanding 62 different
female bodies have
actually been identified as his killers
and i'm sure that there are more bodies
out there there's a continuing
investigation still going on with the
ones that were never identified and we
know some of these weren't listed as
homicides they were listed as
either overdose deaths or they fell off
a ravine
sometimes the damage wasn't readily
available
to say that it was a homicide and some
of these were mislabeled
i wish the hell i didn't but it can't be
true
in fact i mean not only respond to the
war that i'm
ready for and i'm constantly saying i'm
sorry yes sir
well for this family they have closure
now you know you've
confessed to it you've told us what you
did how you did it why you did it
and i personally thank you for that is
it possible though
that little told investigators
everything or
could he be responsible for more
killings that we don't know about
i believe he's responsible for about the
number that he actually said
93. i found it to be very credible as
far as that
he was not boasting he was very
matter-of-fact he wasn't trying to be
the
worst of the worst my only suspicion
is that there might be men tell me about
mary anne she's what you not they
call a transgender there are three
transgender women
in his victims in the confessions if
there are
victims who did not confess to i think
there were men
while the work continues to verify
little's crimes
unfortunately for authorities he can no
longer help
samuel little died in 2020.
he was rattled at the end
he was definitely going downhill he
would say i'm not on my deathbed yet but
i've done everything in this life now
but die
and i was like no you haven't because
you're gonna help me and we're gonna
find more of these victims
sam made me his next of kin
his family doesn't want anything to do
with him
so i got the call i'm still dealing with
his possessions his remains
with sam being dead it's a loss because
i couldn't go back and check details
with him sam little may have provided
much needed closure to both law
enforcement
and the victim's loved ones but in the
end
it never changed who he was or what he
did
mr little was not sorry about anything
that he did
he was at one point trying to say that
he felt bad
for the women that he killed he had
nothing to say about the families and
the devastation that he caused
across america he was a
parasite and
he deserves to be where he is right now
in the grave where he sent so many women
and that's our story on the shocking
terrifying and tragic case
of samuel little one we had never seen
before
and hopefully one we never see again
that's all we have for you here on prime
crime
leave us your comments on instagram and
twitter with the hashtag prime crime
as always thank you for joining us and
until next time
be safe
[Music]
you